not for decades has the relationship
between our two Nations been so
important
the values we share our belief in
Freedom democracy and the rule of law
have never changed they never will
but what has changed are the challenges
that we face
and standing here together as our
predecessors have done for Generations
I feel confident that through the
strength of our relationship
we can shape the world once again in our
pursuit of Liberty prosperity and the
possibilities of a new age
and that begins with our highest
priority National Security
last time I was here in the U.S we
signed orcas
the most significant defense partnership
in Generations
because we recognize that the security
of the Atlantic and Pacific regions
are indivisible and just a fortnight ago
in Hiroshima President Biden and I stood
with president zielinski and our G7
allies in a powerful display of unity
the UK is proud of our contribution
including providing tanks long-range
weapons and training Ukrainian soldiers
but let no one doubt
U.S leadership and resources are the
decisive contribution allowing the
forces of democracy and freedom to
prevail
as I said in Congress
and I say again now to President Biden
and to the American people
thank you
and just as we collaborate to protect
our national security
so must we increasingly do the same to
protect our Economic Security on which
our prosperity depends
countries like China and Russia are
willing to manipulate and exploit our
openness steal our intellectual property
use technology for authoritarian ends or
withdraw crucial resources like energy
they will not succeed
today we have agreed the Atlantic
declaration
a new economic partnership for a new age
of a kind that has never been agreed
before
yes a partnership that protects our
citizens
but more than that
a test case for the kind of reimagined
alliances President Biden has spoken so
eloquently about
that means new investment this week
alone 14 billion pounds of new American
Investment has been committed into the
UK creating thousands of jobs
it means stronger Supply chains with a
new action plan on clean energy
and it means reducing trade barriers and
the Technologies of the future
with a new secure UK US data Bridge
helping tens of thousands of small
businesses
an agreement to work towards Mutual
recognition of more professional
qualifications in areas like engineering
and we're launching negotiations on a
new critical minerals agreement
once concluded this will give UK
companies stronger access to the U.S
market
and we're building on our extraordinary
shared strengths in cutting-edge future
Technologies with joint research
collaborations and areas like quantums
semiconductors and AI
now our job as Leaders is to ensure that
this technological Revolution makes us
more secure and not less
last week the pioneers of artificial
intelligence warned us about the scale
of the challenge as well as the
opportunity
the US and the UK are the world's
foremost Democratic AI powers
so today president and I agreed to work
together on AI safety including
multilaterally
now the UK looks forward to hosting the
first Global Summit on AI safety later
this year
so that we can seize the extraordinary
possibilities of this new technological
age and do so with confidence
and we are well placed to do so
I know some people have wondered what
kind of partner Britain would be after
we left the EU
I'd say judge us by our actions
we're committed to our values as ever
as reliable an ally as ever as
attractive an investment destination as
ever
but we're changing too
we're strengthening our relationships
not just with old friends like America
and in Europe but with new friends in
the indo-pacific too
and we now have the freedom to regulate
the new technologies that will shape our
economic future like AI more quickly and
flexibly
that is the future that we are creating
in Britain confident proud and free